during the pandemic i've been asking
everyone the same two first questions
uh and i'm gonna continue with that
today uh what is the tv show you would
love to guest star on
yeah i'd say like like an animated show
maybe
big mouth or
simpsons the simpsons would be great
uh what movie or movies do you think
you've seen the most
probably the harry potters i watched
i watched them a lot growing up yeah i
was i was really into them
have you seen all eight of them like the
same amount
where you'd start with the first one and
just keep going i'm not sure
i'm not sure you know i think i i i've
had my favorites but they're a great
comfortable watch they just sort of
they just bring back my childhood
basically they're very like nostalgic
completely i i actually i completely
understand that
um one of the things that i really
jumping into why i get to talk to you
one of the things i like is when movies
talk about
like real future like like even though
there's a science fiction movie
this is stuff that could actually be
happening down the road on our planet
can you sort of talk about that aspect
of the film
one of the big draws of a lot of sci-fi
films is that there is this very real
kind of aspect to them of it becoming a
possibility in the future
um yeah it's
it is it's it's it's quite uh
it just kind of it adds a level of
realness to
it i think and and it just it
excites you that bit more to know that
this is something that could be a
possibility
completely one of the things that's cool
about your character or as an actor i
would imagine with this role is that
you essentially are playing two
different people you know you start out
the movie
essentially like a robot um you know
like you're a certain way and then by
the end
you're completely different uh was that
like could you sort of talk about that
aspect of your character and
how nice that was to play as an actor it
was amazing it was really amazing to
play such a
such a gift um as an actor to be given a
role like
like zach and
that like you were saying that kind of
juxtaposition of the sort of numb
uh state they're all in at the beginning
and then that kind of
leading to that like manic
off the blue kind of way of being
um it's yes it's it's a lot of fun
uh there the movie is primarily about a
few people
but the the all 30 of the cast are like
it's all the same actors you know you're
working you don't have extras coming in
each day you're working with the same
people
um i'm just curious what the hell was
that like in terms of like
off offset i mean it was it a fun shoot
was it one of these like talk a little
bit about because you had some really
cool people working on this
yeah i i've had a lot of fun i had a lot
of fun it was it was hard work for sure
um we did very like long hours and and
those sets were so claustrophobic and
it was the middle of summer as well um
so it was really
really boiling in those uh plastic
costumes um but it was a
it was hard work but it was a lot of fun
and we we really
had a lot of fun making it and um
yeah it was really it was great i look
back on it with a lot of fun memories
one of the things that um i don't people
won't realize us are watching
but there's no sunlight in this movie
you're in sound stages the entire time
led lighting at what point did you start
going crazy on during the shoot
uh i'd say halfway through it did start
to feel a bit
groundhog day and it's when they would
open when you do a whole day of filming
and you'd be inside the whole time in
this set
and then they open the doors at the end
of the day to the stage
and sunlight would flood in and you'd
kind of like realize how out of them
out of work you were i'm a big fan of
neil
uh neil's work and uh he always he can
do some interesting camera shots and
there's some in this movie with the
the long corridor can you sort of talk
about collaborating with neil
maybe what surprised you about working
with him he's a brilliant
director and and writer just kind of
reputation
uh is incredible um
and he he really lives up to it as well
he's very meticulous
in his directing and very able to like
to pick out small details in your
performance
or in in a scene and just alter them
slightly to fit his
um to fit his image for it he's got a
very clear picture in his head i think
very detailed and then clear picture
instead of what he wants and he knows
exactly how to just
do tiny little tweaks to to get it
uh there's something in this movie
without going into spoilers it's
it's in the second half where uh the
people are presented with facts
and they sort of don't want to buy into
it even though it's right in front of
them
and it really reminds me of the real
world and what happened with
election fraud and with january 6th
and all this stuff and it's um it's just
it's very interesting
uh and obviously when you're making the
film you couldn't have known
uh you know real you didn't know stuff
like this was gonna happen but can you
sort of talk about
the like the film does a very good job
of dealing with human nature
yeah totally um it's kind of like the
big question
throughout the film is morality and
humanity and
what what makes us human and why we
should be good and all the rest of it
um and one of the kind of things that
becomes clear
in the film is that all the characters
need each other
you know to to survive um
and i think that's a really important
message to kind of put out is that we
really do
need each other um that kind of sense of
community and
togetherness is it's something that is
really strong um
and very important uh i want to jump
backwards for a second with you i'm a
big fan of black mirror
and you got to be a part of that um it
was a cool episode
can you talk about what you remember
about making that episode and
um i'm just curious what it was like
working on that
it was a hard shoot it was it was really
tricky because there was so much going
on we we
were filming six days a week
um and we shot the whole thing in six or
six and a half weeks
and it's four and a half hours of
coverage overall
um so it's it was a lot it was like
getting through a lot of material
and it was extremely confusing to
because we'd be doing a scene and then
we'd go we'd go to move on and then the
director would be like
david who's brilliant he'd be like oh
[ __ ] no we've got go back and we've
gotta do
this variation of that scene so we've
gotta do do it in
four different ways one of them is like
you don't know anything
second version is like you're getting a
bit savvy to it third version is like
you know exactly what's going on the
fourth origin version is like going
crazy there was like all these
it was like a scale you know of um of
deja vu almost
um so it was very it was very it was
tricky but it was a game i had a lot of
fun on it and i made
like i was lucky enough to work with
incredible
actors and crew and david the director
and
with charlie and everything so i just
feel really really lucky to have been a
part of it
yeah yeah it's a cool episode i gotta go
i'm just gonna say congrats
wish you nothing but the best and good
luck with your speed dating
thank you very much